ba-ba-ba-ba so most original half-life
to be fair dude big guys in here that
was literally the thing I missed most
from the game so far that it hasn't
really been that scary you know I'm
saying look at this guy he knows what
I'm saying it's not right yep
don't be scared don't be scared there
there's cute little lines once you see
them you will you will laugh and [ __ ]
yourself because I'm how funny they are
to look at where's there's something up
there yeah alright so down the creepy
cave we go
I'll have the shot shouting ready for
show it's kind of cute and like they
light it up nice again females loved it
I don't understand why my senses are so
bad
I think this channel is so filled with
spam and and people [ __ ] posting that
it's hard to tell like genuine support
sometimes someone I was sad I was
thinking about just posting them
privately people were immediately a lot
more supportive which I appreciate it's
nice to get sometimes a tampon a night
there has to be a resin in here there
just has to be
I remember guys man it's funny how they
show that in early in the game when you
had no idea what it was for that's what
I'm talking about
that's what I modified liberating it
everyday talking about that's what I'm
talking hey I hate him he's so lame Alex
- I'm sorry you sucker this is my
opinion
indocin stares in our heads
guys I don't know about you I'm kind of
a hacker not gonna lie all right what
kind of drugs do that we having here
unlabeled oh I should be fine we have 45
resin I think our gun is upgraded enough
but let's see bullet rests around I
don't need that what about this gun
extended magazine reflex sight no to the
shotgun grenade launcher yes please all
my money all my money you can have it
you can have it you can have it I don't
even like money that much that's a line
but you can have it anyway all right now
you're just being greedy Oh push grenade
push handle forward to ready grenade
launcher and fire or fire to attack
normally okay we should where's the
handle this one
okay so it basically means I can shoot
grenades someone's like it's a grenade
launcher or something like that that's
kind of weird
who invented that that'd be weird
imagine inventing the grenade launcher
be like brah people die epic eight
supping obviously dying man all right
but video game epic so I see there's a
[ __ ] off come come come
[Music]
all right Jeff
now it's on
alright we're gonna use they're not that
strong guys don't worry yes that's an
antlion right down you look like you got
some legs am i right
I don't got legs what aah knock it off
you two
yeah me too kinky [ __ ] what's up
find specimen I must say fascinating
what they can do these years these
Dave's exit how great look at that
whoa they got the sentries I remember
this so fun
Hey look forget the thing they owe the
great outdoors it's so pretty look at
the gradient of the sky and the way need
shadows their reflection so pretty oh my
God look at these the Lotus looking
things very good Hey look at em oh I saw
I saw it in the beginning to be honest I
thought I wouldn't grab it just to piss
you guys off and then lose it again
wonder what kind of secrets are in this
game that people have discovered you
know
all right let's go let's go yeah we're
in a museum that's so cool hey I see you
in there I'm not afraid of lions okay
the only people afraid of lions are high
in ice because they get eaten by them
and I don't get you I get that guys
definitely in my life
surprise [ __ ]
surprise [ __ ] surprise
[ __ ]
surprise mother a girl you look good
yeah [ __ ] a resin during me resin resin
resin resin a nice place [ __ ]
all right what was he doing in here I
think just coming here for some resin I
wasted shotgun ammo come on seriously
they do me like that sometimes though
alright who's in here alright who's in
here come out come out your mom is
waiting come out stop it
I told I told him to stop it you're
beautiful I understand this is there
nothing in here unfortunate
okay do be like that sometimes though
hey resins if there's resins will be
rising into the sunshine and I put the
drugs what hey hey
[ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] what what are you
hiding from me huh you having I am own
[ __ ] for me some people never learn man
some people never learn man all right a
commercial if you catched it on my
catched it first no I'll just carry in
my hands that's cool look at the sky oh
look at the land
don't look at the lion lion yeah I did
this man jumped on
[ __ ] attached attaches attached
just just attach one of those grenades
they they're everywhere resin yeah yeah
what are you guys huh what do you got I
know you'll have something having on you
yeah yeah
bye-bye mother
sit the [ __ ] down
hey sit down [ __ ] that I've got this 11
[Applause]
crippled people can't fight me crippled
people can't fly away so I can just
shoot the butt okay
I wasted a lotta Emma there all right I
won't use the shotgun I thought for some
reason shotgun would be useful I'm the
one with the legs I'm the one with the
legs mother [ __ ] I can try a reson card
it
I got an eagle a you gotta give it props
to me right huh
we got on you
resin resin is resonating resin rabbit
little Michael little Michael hold up
little Michael midlet of sting II Oh
singing I'll get you out of there
I'll get you know Michael son don't
worry
you got an angular I'll see you there
there's me so good
did you see that no no no no no no it's
a mistake it's a mistake it's a mistake
don't tell anyone oh my daily quarantine
exercise squatting oh my god everyone
now is clearly working out right all
right hit him hit him in the deck it's
really hard to hit that part oh my god
stop moving stop moving
[Music]
okay that was pathetic I got it but like
sit down
can you stop you're embarrassing your
son
your whole family's watching him you Dan
whoa that's so cool I'm very excited
something today
dude your foots looks like trees did all
right what do we got here planes we got
plants we got clients and more plant all
right listen
that's where we're going all right let's
all right then
what do you have on you huh or nice or
anything else I don't think so Oh
doesn't quite want to do it no no one
escapes from me
there's nothing deeper than me what do
you have on you poor ppppp I made it
three game that's why that's gonna be a
trial let's check it first
hey come to me I heard I heard the sound
of a resin you hear them very faintly
[Music]
you're here and somewhere over here
I hear you yeah found you
okay we go we go we go we go beans now
we go we go bean singh bath now
I missed it what is that that's a trap
that's a trap I knew it I will take this
thank you very stop it it's my birthday
what kind of mask - do they have is
there a pig one hey that's a tiger just
a kitty cat my cat I'm a kitty cat
I know dance dance dance and I dance
dance dance can't really see where this
thing on
resin as resonating alright I think seen
anything
although send you in here alone it's a
jungle dude that's a freaking junk with
in this jungle I'm a jungle boy true
blood blue Lara and I bet you the many
of it they didn't ever do cover
Queen Queen oh my god Queen take off
take everything take it next to Queen
hail Queen another one
sorry about that [ __ ] you better not
have been simple out on me huh who else
do you give this to you don't give these
to anyone right
I wonder I won there [ __ ] you I don't
give a [ __ ]
give me then I definitely need that more
all right we're good
we Gucci my gamer was brewing my gamer
got that enchanted [ __ ] I don't want to
waste them
proceeds to waste ammo cheek says [ __ ]
away from me who's out there
I'm one more lion since then he bet he
been Symphony CC you got me [ __ ] it
used to be so hard to say something it's
easy everything's perfect please don't
change sting the little thing for me Oh
ah
[Music]
duh
cuz sampling is easy
you got me [ __ ] the eggs they're bees so
hard to say sip give me the other one
seven is easy and everything's perfect
maybe some ginger single a little ding
dummy am I missing something we gucci
my girl my queen I love you gimme give
it away
do not resist I told her I pulled her oh
it's you - sit down mother I say access
sit down mother
yeah huh
are you serious he actually hit me where
I bounced off for me I took a lot of
damage sorry it's alright I got my queen
my queen
howling mcbean
another one please you can do it I knew
it I knew it I knew you had it in you
and knew it another one I knew it I have
a feeling I'm gonna have enough grenades
so I'm gonna do that I played the whole
game with him I might as well keep going
all right I'm not a I don't let people
just go because they're no longer
convenience to me like that's not cool
man
that can't be bothers check all the way
in there
did you know gorillas can rip you in
half
Jim put that put put that up on the
screen whatever its name
why were they put this room here a
circle Rilla yeah there's definitely
gonna be a gorilla I climbed the tower
now I don't all right I'm just looking
around I'm just looking around in the
jungle queen goodbye Queen goodbye
hey grenades it [ __ ] is everywhere hey
want one bro did they're free all you
gotta do is donate to the e-girls that's
only got it there it's pretty awesome
dampeners easy well maybe they uncovered
yeah they tracked it to an old apartment
building and the QC but instead of going
in to get it
now again grab the whole building and
built a fault around it holy crud mud
resin that's my penis it's in there they
locked it up the figure a way to contain
power are you doing this Michael
alright he's good this one does not have
glance drugs don't do kids drugs I've
been telling you guys you got to make
sure you listen no Tristan is gonna
escape for me all right
and nothing I am not afraid the Bresson
wonder what's happened over there seem
like party
I like party smarty can I go in here
feels like I can go in there no Sookie
hello is it okay
ah damn it
you'll pay for this my dad works at
Nintendo
thank you was that so hard
failure oh my god damn failure oh my
queen
oh my Korean for my green my green green
green yeah all right where was I
oh yes god damn it dude dude I'm sorry
Oh
[Laughter]
make them pay I'll make them pay for 100
stay away stay awake Whipple's crazy oh
my gosh [ __ ]
[Music]
I mean we made it Jeff and we made it we
made it Jeffy boy Jeff we made it uh-huh
can't believe it thought I was a goner
there for a second huh may you thought I
was a goner there for a second hey
Man Man Man Man now that's not that we
do it what kind of a rapper what gonna
forever that's how I got my strings
alright we can go in there but there's
just a door here kind of haunt that mine
all day mine all night mine non-stop
till I find the secret inside and I mind
your mom a mine dude gold mine your life
you're alive and I know it
wake up you actually then
he would live here with you wouldn't
live now and I'll make used good oh my
god you're so annoying get this side
away my god you're eight three two one
yay
[Music]
okay
I lost my I lost my my [ __ ] can I
have my hand in the back please guess
it's not it's really not coming back is
it
I don't really need two hands to be fair
flip down show me yourself
pathetic dude Oh
yeah yeah I take them I take them I
smoke them I choke them
hey hey I like that I like that what is
whatever happened in there I like it now
I can't use my other hand anyway I don't
want to restart the game it takes me out
of the experience you know I mean I'm
strong when you want
I can't reload though I think about it
yeah probably
all right well it's not good for either
come on come on yes all right
don't ever do that again don't ever ever
do you know anyone you know Oh
all that hold up something happening in
real life am i breathing a bit loud for
you guys it's not loud for me I sister
the microphone I'm staying
come what the hell it doesn't react to
it anymore
I lost my super ability dagger wiggle
what's in there
Here I am minding my own business thesis
he had keys on them but I don't think I
think that was just a texture thing all
right don't yeah I could actually use
some help
[Music]
not sure with that this oh no thanks
how are you dying here out of all places
huh you could have eaten this guy
do you understand how it tastes it
doesn't work
it's just a gravity that doesn't work
all right what do you got on you
huh what do you got on you what do you
have on you they always have something
little little child lick the little
child you will be sacrifice my little
child licked a little child heal me yeah
you shall later little shall give me
[Music]
little shall give me strength
well what resin it's resting up there
what thought for sure I figure this game
out where they hit this stuff resin here
I said nope I thought I had no I can't
all right this is awkward
let's give me I can't do that
I'm gonna restart it again I will my
handwork
yes I forgot about that I tried to warn
there my swear [ __ ]
use affinity I use a Finnish super Dan
that's right
I got grenades for the haters hey who
are you
Amazon delivery you ordered this hey
resting in s payment I'll take you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
give me that give me that what time is
it it's time to dead what Oh more drugs
I like this remember kids when I said
about drugs do them as much as you can
experiment all right
don't end up like this guy no no no like
that guy and boy yourself [ __ ] don't do
that don't do that that's all I'm gonna
say that's all I'm gonna say I usually
don't talk about these things or usually
you don't have opinion on controversial
topics but drugs yeah something just
ticked away here notice I'm janky my
beer became at us and nowhere are we
still doing this
you've come this far I say we keep going
and if you find out it's something that
really shouldn't mess with it we'll call
it off
that's my ground I'm I'm pretty sure
it's gonna be something that we
shouldn't mess with just gonna just
gonna put my odds on that one for the
for this one oh look at that
that's tricky to find hey my precious
ears just almost got the British irate
that damn girl what are you what are you
alright
bling bling blong bling bling blong
bling bling blong what you don't like
electricity now you don't like
electricity now hmm
from there I just want to shoot people
sorry I said that a bit random but I
don't know I'm missing a lot of combat
that's all I want big farmer break brain
give me that that's a trustworthy brand
that's a trustworthy brand if I ever saw
one
alright what do we got in here hello
so anyone and now dad we got some resin
give me some resin yeah see it I see it
I see it I see it
ah a little trapped air we found it we
[ __ ] found anyway all right all right
all right there's a hat up there might
be useful
hep I had now I had now they had now hey
now
so did I not do the getting pass all
right that's so annoying
what'd I do wrong god this is making me
nauseous dude all right maybe it's here
see you you see it's you you little
nipple thing hello oh my god
yeah oh yeah we're doing all kinds of
stuff it's funny how I didn't show up
before
how was I supposed to avoid that don't
do it
that reactions are just like so on made
that low and health I don't know I don't
know man I'm a little nauseous look at
all I feel a little dizzy felt a little
woozy that's how you know you're
supposed to dude you look good
that's how you know when it's time to
keep playing we're gonna beat the game
together like I promised my love I came
back for you I love you I love you so
goddamn much
dude did you see that you did not you
did not see what I meant
oh my god they gave me no time to react
to the most epic thing I've ever seen in
the air he flipped it on my head right
on top of it and he landed on top of my
head clip that so I clip that dude that
was awesome
ha ha the general resident cabaco made
me a black eye on feet though I did it
now let's dip and go dip and go dip and
go
your mom's ah alright let's see if we
can make him flip out on me twice stab
you're sick alright do it I'm ready
I'm still on completely still come on do
it do it please so what did the other
guy come from he came from behind some
laughs do it come on do it come on do it
come on do it
little tiger creature put it on you
stinky all right they wouldn't hurt a
cat were they they wouldn't possibly
hurt our kitty can and that dance dance
dance in a dance that's what I thought
surprise I'm not a cat at all
show me show me show me what you got
show me what you got
he's got keys Oh Phil don't think about
it don't think about it just keep
playing feel good leg less leg less
pathetic Bader where's your legs big
open I get that good ah sorry
ready buco that's good Emma don't worry
I got you
I'm at a [ __ ] got you
I'll never leave you alone again I'll
leave Marseille for you [ __ ] a [ __ ]
leaver sit there I got you
if only we can make you hear laughs if
only
we'll get marry in the few words of
Satan we don't have kids but it's okay
eight eight eight all right all right
let's just pull the ANSP all these are
for some reason these are tricky I don't
oh it's cuz they got no electricity all
right so it goes in there uh-huh
all right and it goes there uh-huh all
right and then it goes oh then we see
this in the trailer resonate when I'm on
I'm scanning you can't go on bad read
Hey found you I keep finding them I keep
finding them I'm so good at [ __ ]
finding the tabi
whoa what are you you're so cute
oh my god it's a team for tonight's
figure that's so cool
manaman sometimes it's actually worth
shooting these good cuz they drop ammo
and stuff ah make it rain see what I see
it I mean he dropped ammo whole new
brand mm oh don't worry good hey let's
put the team fortress next a tiger like
their friends now
alright I had to pull solve the puzzle I
forgot all right so we got electricity
and I did I not I need to go back in
connector I hit the keyboard I might
have okay we're fine it's gotta be
careful
Oh No ah too fast [ __ ] splash
splash [ __ ]
where's boot grandpa please bird it's me
I'm surprised you alright if it's not
what you all wanted TV you're gonna have
to come out you're gonna have to come
out TV yeah oh nice steve-o some balls
right in your face
nice one Gabe did you ask for that one
let's put a half-life rest in and then
let's put some balls in their mouths
yeah
they'll enjoy that one I mean team
fortress right
balls in my face balls in my face gave
no Bell puts balls in my face
guys half-life 2 half-life 3 half-life
Alex it's a great game at all
but like it doesn't really like where's
the part where they put balls balls in
people's faces Gabe I don't think that's
a balls all right Gabe you wait this is
sit up let down go back to where you
came from go down yeah go down in there
there you go
all better where's food whatever boo
food
but what's up milk boat
where is he just gonna show him he'll
come back he'll come back he'll come
back to me they all do
but this ain't a game this ain't a game
I have to get out I forgot about that I
don't like this he keeps running from me
I treat him like a queen all they must
have taken boots oh they'll pay for that
huh what do you have on you where is it
this is not cool guys
I lost him I [ __ ] lost him Wow all
right that sounds spooky
we got heal station hey little girl Hey
don't oh sorry sorry don't worry don't
worry don't worry
hey don't cry don't cry don't cry Hey
look a friend all right don't worry
we're all gonna make it out of here once
I find boot and it's all gonna be okay
trust me he's a great guy
once you get to know him he smells like
feet though but that's kind of
I better still have him all right go
back to your homes
inside my wrist
have you seen poot have you seen him
I don't know about you guys but I think
he's lying
there's got to be a resin in here I know
it a smell resin that smell smell smell
the Rams in resin all right [ __ ] it
think we're OK Hey Oh God
we got a sneak
oh my god whoa
Russell boys just returned the last yes
son of a boat my legs
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] man that is
so flippin cool dude
this alien ants ever you hey hat
hey who wants one who want some come get
some
I'm not afraid of lions because they
like our table how turn tables
milk
then you give away my location hey go
away
oh it cont takes
that water hey that's my that's my movie
this is a nice car stop yes ah flipping
hair is gone all right oh god oh god
[ __ ] and that's how we do it in
[ __ ] ji-hae [ __ ] resin I
haven't found that Sharon yes what is
this poor town where poor people live
huh give me that hey give me that
yeah [ __ ]
resin come on man I'm guessing we're
going up there should I shoot up there
it's really tempting to get anything
will happen I did it for the meme we
left
sometimes memes pace sometimes means
don't pace he's got to live with the
consequences hey stop talking stop
talking stop speaking mouth movements
they're gonna pay for this and they're
gonna pay for what they did to you at
boot
where is he who's the traitor let me
guess the girl from the beginning wow
that's good right is very very good
miracle all right so let's go save
Gordon Freeman sir incoming hey give me
a second what
what am I supposed to do here or shoot
him in the answer that wall is gonna
break you know it it's like in cartoons
when it looks like the portal thing
doesn't it I just yeah open that thing
come on yeah it's me
Hey look at that I'm so surprised my god
look I can see him okay so the plan is
so hot I want to [ __ ] him this is this
is Gordon and I worth it oh yes please
daddy not milk
not now milk so he went to the alien
dimension didn't he I don't never played
a their original I never played the
original I play
all right thing did all right sue me sue
me please all right you can't because
all the courts are down right I move
this
yes please
already got a hat
we should get throw a grenade down there
all right
my mouth shut down by the way guys
catchy
no that wasn't for you that was not for
you let it go fine what a cozy little
area we live here huh me and but yes
[Music]
okay we're together forever we're gonna
get married one day boot boot gang boot
boot gang boot boot gang sure term
good job flux thanks booting you're the
main boot gang almost look around Ole
Miss
oh no we cool yeah I'm gonna guess we're
not cool stop back what did he shoot
exactly I wonder if I can do this
nope well that's where we were before I
assume I can't go in here oh wow they're
they're milking the cows okay nice
I hope they taste good I love to have
some milk milk milk
no Mel what I'm not looking at them
around as much as I I said milk tastes
good good job she looks
I know [ __ ] we're gonna make it out of
lime
dude you're ugly oh my god
boot do your thing all right we're out
of needs
bad butt
we have risen it's gonna make sure booth
doesn't get stuck in the ground that's
like my only alright but we have to go
up there I'll be right there okay can I
use anything no hmm I am missing
something obvious that thing perhaps yep
but I'm coming oh no boot I'm coming I'm
coming my right touch controller
battery's low but Oh
I'll thank you I'm coming
oh not the toilet really gate first the
poles and now this boots on boot but
I'll meet you on the other side
this is bad gamers it's awesome
oh this is really bad okay yeah oh
ain't nobody booked with a boat
alright let's go
come on hold it okay I got damnit that'd
be so cool in another game I will get
boots a gun the one that was a boom
how did not touch that I did not touch
that Wow I did it boo thank you for your
support you're the main I love you
you've been a father figure to me for my
entire life I know that despite our
differences we can flip and get out of
here alive one day or another one boon
I'm gonna be real with you don't ever do
that again alright alright let's not
mess this up I'm gonna throw you alright
all right I'm gonna crouch down and then
I'm gonna throw you know III don't want
three too much
come on boo oh that's good
you good oh all right what's this what I
do what I do what I do say it again
Boop
I mean got time Baskin that's definitely
gonna come along
all right boot distract them yeah I have
to be [ __ ]
I can't believe it you [ __ ] [ __ ]
what do you think you're doing are they
let me [ __ ] strangle you give me that
I've only loved one thing in my life and
you took it from me drugs
[Music]
how am I supposed to get that maybe it's
for later I need to remind myself if I
see something in this ceiling alright
gamer to remind me remind me are the
ceilings all right look I did it at the
aim at the funkin alright how do I do
this I'm gonna die I'm gonna die this is
really bad
alright so I know there's a secret if I
shoot that day yeah come down to me
[Music]
Jesus I thought i teleported there so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna shoot
that through the head and now we can
blow it up my resin resin a found you
how do you know I need you
stop trying stop trying
stop trying buddy once you're missing a
link the world is gonna know me and
there she is there she blows
I think the child
baby baby oh oh okay
Sergei Sergei ah along my god I don't
even feel like upgrading it anymore oh
dude that took a long eight get down
from there
all right what do we got
how about I've graded everything already
did I do all that for nothing
seriously I don't need to upgrade
anything bullet restaurant well I think
we're getting near the end of the game
shades too you might hey is that running
joke all right so this is where I came
from I forgot I was in there for so long
no it's not where I came from now I'm
confused whereas most will go
shame on you I like that that's funny
I made promises to two boys in this game
and I intend to keep them
you understand getting a little tired in
my back to stand up I mean it I also
have leg day today so it's it's not
ideal
yeah show me your ass show me your ass
see they always show my ass all right
but we got this don't be scared don't be
scared
you scared Bo
all right this is definitely
battleground bow no no no
hold on one second guys
that [ __ ] threw an eighth at me
how many times should we have to
separate
[Music]
Oh
fireworks
[Applause]
come here [ __ ] come close I'm on
the [ __ ] burn [ __ ] Oh
stop that stop right there criminal scum
oh this bad
goodnight
I said goodnight
how they're shooting me from there
I'll take that yeah
[Applause]
you know it's serious now huh
Wow out
sit the [ __ ] down [ __ ]
sit the [ __ ] down be
[Music]
Wow
I don't see my gun I don't I can't see
my gun
[Applause]
[Music]
use a thinner down
hey Russ you want to swap in here that
was nasty
Oh ain't nobody [ __ ] with the P man
ain't nobody [ __ ] with the female
ain't nobody [ __ ] with a female yeah
that was straight from the dick and you
liked it straight from the J and I liked
welcome back gamers we're in a stealth
mission to save Gordon Freeman whoa holy
moly that's bad oh god it's raining
stuff why does it look like I'm flying
I'm not flying it's where gamers resin
gamma dummy oh that would've been a
perfect this is sparta moment I may I
I may have messed that one up alright
let's climb up alright I've done this
many times before I know I didn't climb
I I'm hitting something in real life
while I'm under the table come on safety
I made it past the table that's the
table yeah alright let's not do that
there has to be something here I refuse
to believe there's enough no secret here
hey buddy hey god damn I want to put my
penis there god damn why do I have to
say what's on my mind not that I want to
say it because it is on my mind it's
just
I know you would come back oh let's put
this on all right so this is the last
episode I know because I've been
speaking to Jack Jack said I will really
like the last episode you're the real
one because the real when it comes to
singles you're a fake one I was I knew a
little lower
yeah of course of course how is that I
still don't know how to play this game
all right I think we're gonna see Gordon
Freeman
but that's my theory because that would
be cool right that would be a big
shocker because you never see Gordon
Freeman
but now you're in VR you're like up
close you actually get to like see him
touch his boobs but never not in front
of you of course all right this is my
theory of the ending what is gonna be I
don't know what do you think theories
that should the theory I'm too tall for
this game now I mean I'm always tall
like this is an issue for me now right
broom Oh resin
give it back give it back he's gonna
spit it out isn't he let's see if we can
catch it you [ __ ] just ate it damn it
I missed all right we'll get it later
oh my god guys guys don't throw stuff at
me don't do that
can't believe you didn't die all right
come on show me your teeth
girls always show their titty when I ask
always isn't that right babe all right
sounds like Alex got the correct
markiplier it's good to see you again
all four of you can you believe it
they put a marker play I wonder if I can
put him in the boot like that's pretty
good I should be able to walk now all
right cool we're bringing fruit and
markiplier with us now that's yeah yeah
that's how we play this game all right I
assume here I assume I may be up here
resin No
infestation control a corona actually
Felix it's called the China virus let's
be not offensive here and use the right
terminology all right so this looks like
a puzzle isn't it what are we looking at
here we're looking at a command station
down there and we're looking at some way
to get across to lift the gate we need
to move the pipe I assume we just
control it all from there let's check
out this if I can go actually go in here
I don't think I can now god I'm a little
nauseous every time I start playing Oh
dick flattening dick flattening dick
flattening dude boot yeah I got them
boom sets the foot when I step it yeah
oh my god your life it's a miracle I'm
not gonna lie I'm not gonna sit here and
lie to you show me your teeth
combat is a little too easy and I'm
playing a normal day oh my god I'm too
tall did ya maybe I'll eat those words I
wish I could do this they'd be such a
life hack oh cool it's gonna jam it in
there now we Barry can play oh damn it
alright let's do this this works as well
I literally been playing so much but now
in real life I do this and like I forgot
I forgot the remote come on I see the
resin I see you come here baby I see you
I see you I'm not in the mood of bending
over today not today girls I don't know
why I feel like eating this alright
nevermind you get to live it's your
lucky day Mike if you're [ __ ] lucky a
mate oh this is very annoying not gonna
lie
alright
cool put it in Alex put it inside you
please so annoying all right how we
looking good looking PewDiePie smoking -
koukin plugin Hey look looking I don't
need more action I happen uh alright
alright
boot will you go in the pipe and check
if it's safe that's to be a way to get
there I don't think we move the barrels
ahead watch this guy's
no they don't let you I got my boot in
my eyes you go away yeah yeah okay are
you scared boot don't be scared I don't
want to bend over I don't I'm too tall
like this is the ground I'm touching the
ground right now
it's very way to room maybe reset the
view cuz it's kind of annoying
this is the problem when you're really
tall like me and we're saying this for
years literally hey check if it's safe
that's not oh okay one moment sir
show me titties
huh hold on not yet
now now show me titties thank you all
right what we got what we got a gameis
Hey look at that I did a gamer's I did
it open please do I need two drugs
is that even a question always do drugs
kids I mean kids do always drugs
I mean drugs Sookie I'm confused I don't
know what my stands are on on all of
this should I reload my gun yes probably
but I don't feel like it that looks like
a baby face you saw it for a second
didn't you all right let's get it I mean
all right I got the useless part oh come
on I had them
nice
what what's happening
give me hat I look good now I boot you
be the commander while I take over this
ship today's schedule we have a busy day
ahead of us but you take the schedule
all right so we just move this backwards
right well that's a part of that that's
a problem all right
ah
yes that's working all right this guy
he's got wiggle in out really I don't
know how to do that just shoot it here
we go
you could have told me about that boon
come on come on have a gun I thought
there would be an actual puzzle here and
not just the fact that I didn't see the
remote control okay
isn't that right boots we work hard
enough already Midway pathetic you're so
pathetic it's so tempting to shoot them
in the ass every time and I don't know
what that says about me or what it says
about society I'll leave you gamers up
to vote you're not dead are you okay
they're not that hey don't shoot through
the thing guys guys stop it watch this
game remove game removed
excuse me learn English I can't risk
losing you again I can't see cuz there's
a giant text in front of me Oh what
happened there push to bring up jump
indicator and release too Jeff I'm not
ready to jump crazy there's also stuff
here on the sides which is very tempting
to see what that's about right like
there and [ __ ] am I supposed to go there
maybe that's why I'm supposed to go yeah
I think so more planks then we all love
them the more you got them the more you
realize how good life is with them you
know what I mean all right I see you we
have a we have old business to take care
of make it rain don't teach me come on
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm actually low on
knowing I had 110 I read 10 listen
reading is hard
[Music]
okay perfect just got to climb this with
one hand oh come on yeah boot fake boot
these are actually worth checking well I
guess I was wrong
markiplier who did that it feels so
badass doing that alright let's check
around a bit I want to make sure I have
enough stuff for the final battle
because I said the game was too easy so
now if I don't play it perfectly people
are definitely whole gonna hold it
against me
alright cool
nothing like your hand merging with a
with the draws of this game I can't be
bothered I'm a good but you're so useful
people keep saying stop caring god
dammit I don't need to be here what
point of this
this is a bonus thing wasn't a yeah I
think it was just a bonus thing
ah - oh ah - OH
all right fine
they distract it with a sexiness and
then something else comes and kills you
like that doesn't seem fair to me
alright now we can jump no I'm so scared
of throwing stuff yeah there we go
boot check if it's safe thanks boot
you're the man you the man boot you the
man you the man damn own strong ah I
made it up boot yeah
Putin PewDiePie 2024
I love you it's right birthday today
I know I know there will be cake at the
end of this trust me make it rain
[ __ ] update place good point
I'll see if there any upgrades I can
used its new green one show yeah you
want to give your dick to Gordon that's
way she's really saying because Oh God
I don't need to do this cuz I I have all
the upgrades I need and these are kind
of up there's got to be where you get
both for these
[Music]
this one gets three
I did it holy crap I did it I mean of
course of course I didn't brows brows
brows oh it's my mouth sorry
[Music]
so on the shotgun we have not the double
shot maybe the double shot could be fun
we don't afford it
laser sight we don't need
[Music]
wouldn't want to be on the wrong side of
that I love upgrading weapons and stuff
like that but I think oh this is cool
actually it's just a little yeah yeah I
would like it more if let's say you can
go down at Allen tree like Oh in this
run you go for the gun upgrades and this
run you go for them then grades because
then I would feel incentivize to play
the game more than once it's not right
so I'm a bit tired today I can't be back
I can't be bothered have sex with all of
them dude you're so short look at shorty
is that's crazy
I don't know they make them so short
yeah I meant to do that does that ever
happen to you when you're a giant and
you just walk up railings by accident oh
I got it I put down my hands here but
this is not a real table it's getting a
bit hot and complaining a lot aren't I
it's it's tough guys you don't
understand all right baby
I have full help and I think this is one
of the last so I'm gonna leave my friend
here with you his name is Jim
no he's Jeff it wasn't it no that
doesn't work I can't since I can't save
you I will leave you a friend
you guys can talk about politics and
literature and but that huh
that's nice what are you saying you say
thank you goddamn nice body sucks I
don't want to walk up on it clearly
don't forget boot oh my god
it might be for the better I mean no I
need him again
my memory is really bad guys huh I'm
sorry
[Music]
I'm just gonna do this
it hurts to suck isn't it I'm so pulled
look at it I'm so tall Hey look at that
boots well done my man my man Jake a
whacko can't go vote
where did you go oh where did he go
boots ah ah where did he go but you keep
I keep losing him
have you seen
remove the shin
don't think so yeah okay those tight
that like that those fun hats on hats on
to your valve
[Music]
this looks important but it isn't kinda
like me okay cool yo ink and Yoink yeah
that took a lot of you guys hear that
Sweet Home Alabama it's probably gonna
be more enemies where the skies are
green yeah yeah I thought the rise to
personnel on me that's me right are they
in there
where those beans are coming from the
top of this tower right yeah that's
right
Jesus madland absolute Madlen he's crazy
look at fingers though it's very sexy
if only I had boot you know what I mean
he was like a father to me and stuff
like that you know that's bad I can do
the same thing I can do the exact same
thing you can do you understand this
that looks safe hey doing buddy come on
[ __ ]
I've had a clear okay I have that idea
if only I can grab his boots you know
what I mean if only I could just like
take them off or something please
let's not do that again big dive in such
funny positions all right how do I get
up whoa cool area to look over very cool
that's really really cool Wow let me
look let me look at you you're a little
weird oh damn this is so pretty this is
so atmospheric I'm taking it all in dude
amazing I had this theory all right
listen
listen to this theory what the game will
live give me enough time animal crossing
right everyone loves that game you know
why because you're in your own little
area everyone gets their own space
there's no industrial mechanism we're
all just happier
we're all just happier in nature
unconsciously or miss know what the word
is when you stumble upon something
without meaning to simulated exactly
what people want which isn't living in
flats in big cities having day-to-day
jobs they just want to live in their own
little house with enough space that
there's still other people around
hence the villagers so you don't feel
lonely but really you just want to live
you're on your own well house in the
forest because that's where we all
belong and at the end of the day isn't
it no one wants this huh are we happier
because of all of this are we happier
because of the latest iPhone I don't
think so it's temporary pleasures with
living day to day in the happy world
that's what we all really want do you
understand me so Animal Crossing
basically is the key to happiness is
what I'm saying
anytime they figured it out why oh yeah
I can't become so dumb I do need help
excuse me can I shoot them doing it you
can also shoot me through there
big guys coming don't tell them it's the
last one you stink your brainer huh
never tell them I don't have a lot of
ammo right yeah I thought I was on the
last one that's funny hey look I'm good
on help don't worry buddy
don't worry I don't I don't really need
the help and they really got to do me
like this on an old man trying to plan
game after band over in front of his
child yes it looks like you will be able
to get into the vault from up there
what's the security they dragged this
area out so they can do that and text
speech moments one really is annoying
yes I'm on my period today yes thank you
for asking my blood sugar levels I'm not
perfectly balanced therefore I am a
little cranky today
I have not had my G fuel yes
it's cool to be a so up close to it
truly is a sight to be seen
you might even you know in the I guess
my point was like in the future you know
with VR that they're gonna make some
sort of nature simulator that will make
you feel like oh wow it's like I'm
actually in nature know something about
looks like the bridge is fully extended
just need to gently dock the vault to
the bridge
how far can that be oh that yes well one
of these has to bring in the vault for
doggy right maybe no tilt that one
Alex the bridge is moving why is the
Brico moving I know it moving
am i dead am I going to meet God come
beat us all well hey look it disappeared
from the mat that's funny
and I was like a meme with VR and you
have someone sitting in VR but in
reality it's like everything is broken
and just stopped being around one day
especially we clearly simulate games in
a way now well we know you didn't so
it's ok oh my god
it's dog no wait I'm really alone help I
really should have should have yelled
the show tonight
let's check around there might be more
resin you know
I don't think there's any more resin all
right dude
I'm sorry I said no to the other one all
right you understand I didn't say no to
the other one I'm sorry buddy
[Music]
what the hell Oh willingly going down in
hell
we'll be surprised if there weren't no
zombies down here especially since they
just gave me a grenade Shh ah God all
right this better be the life
[Music]
Oh speedrun yeah Sesame Open please
I think I have a lot of shotgun Emma
I've not been using it
here we go gamers I can submit this is
so pretty huh that guy is having a bad
day I almost feel bad for him do they
say alex is so cute say my [ __ ]
name the count of four like Star Wars
characters I don't know it that way of
falling yeah what the hell I don't like
him did it
Mogwai markiplier have you seen boot all
right have you seen him I'm looking for
him it's very important to me no we're
not intimate sexually Jesus why would
you ask that markiplier okay so we did
this one
markiplier come on come on dude help me
what it couldn't possibly where does it
go
ain't nobody know I can't talk to me
like this oh I can just do that that's
funny go on
resin Popkin
yeah yeah some final puzzles I don't
know after a while it's like yeah I get
it
he has the attention span of a
five-year-old yes I know
let's definitely go in here hey buddy I
don't want to keep doing this
yes you get live huh
lucky you markiplier is that you listen
in another life all right
do you understand then such a good song
no no no okay
more breathing
I have to go down on my knees and then
real I have to go back
okay
don't worry guys this is the final one
sweet let's call the elevator why do I
feel like that's gonna come alive
elevators are safe during these
circumcised stations don't shoot me
I didn't even break a sweat
excuse me guys shame we sit now gamers
we incensed with SIDS
[Music]
I'm sorry
sit gang again the strongest gang on
YouTube
sweet sweet I never get a chance to do
it properly
good I'll probably need that a little
long I'm a little low it's whatever
now we all getting low sometime gamers I
don't need how about this we'll do that
might need it later I have a sneaking
suspicion I don't know if I can reach
I'm serious miss this funny oh we better
get out of here real fast my spaghetti
Holmes got spaghetti homes in them
[Music]
they are running the new drugs I run in
a new growth high road and a new drug
I'd won and I do drugs I I roll never do
drugs
that's a bro and a new Brooks
[Music]
i rana they do grubs Oh Rhonda mad you
drove [ __ ] around an engine crux what
this is our shooting crab London do
drugs
[Music]
they're like suck masturbating girls
again
goodbye
Ronna dude room my nipples we did it
excuse me this is not common in Russia I
didn't oh no that's bad I think
let's not let's not shall we
it's healing that's so nice I'm not sure
what I'm doing
of course Jesus maybe I should wait I'm
gonna guess that when they said it was
gonna be fine it's not actually going to
be fine that's just you know I'm kind of
a detective it's probably because I read
a lot of literature and I understand
expectations and set up a memory
sequence yes where me Gordon Freeman is
actually my dad and I've been crushing
out on my dad this whole time that'd be
cool
all right pan game bang game oh my god
oh my god I am paying gang bang gang
bang gang
Gordon are you in here while you part of
the pan gang perhaps
this is a veteran Oyen we're gonna get
tangled up we keep adding up gamers
cool
I'm not picking my nose I'm just
scratching it
two very different things it looks
incredible
it honestly does the art direction is 10
out of 10 well done
I guess that's the vault
by where does pan gang belong
[Music]
really okay
unexpected I don't think there's a point
in looking and I don't think maybe he
strikes maybe I don't know like what's
the point
hmm I'm strong
oh that's creepy now I got it whoa that
is extremely trippy dude do you think I
can make the transition all right fine
if gravity doesn't apply to girls huh
sexes
you scare me all right so we have a man
the story is like man with calculator
checks his mail and gravity just turns
on himself
we've all been there all right now we're
upside down this is very strange
I don't know I prefer when there were
balls in my face I like that part more I
think they oh that's funny I didn't
think of that
Piang gang good thing I'm wearing this
hat cuz otherwise pang gang could be in
big trouble where are you going with
this I keep forgetting so strange
hello
well gang where's food you must have in
somewhere
[Music]
Bert
buuut I'm scared I'm scared where is he
where is he please sir
sir it's fun slapping him oh thank you
Oh God
have you seen him stretch and you will
find my god he must be here somewhere
I can smell him this door doesn't okay
we were gonna get married
[Music]
whoa trippy dude don't play this on
drugs dude
oh my god is so weird I'm looking down
but not really you're trying to make me
sick
oh this is so weird oh my god toothbrush
deodorant have you seen him he must be
here somewhere for [ __ ]
oh jesus lord
[Music]
interesting didn't expect to be here to
be honest
[Music]
I guess that's one way to move houses
guys that I love you
[Music]
what is it what do you think they
discovered a time travel machine or
something cool this is gorgeous
oh it's just like the first game yeah I
love this
oh I got I got this epic gamer in a
style there right now I just throw them
oh I hit the blowing button
I got out of the game come on don't try
it Anakin
bro you're in big trouble
I try to warn him
no more oh this is it
thanks for sticking with my channel
things and since I know
conveniently placed
don't you it
thank goodness I keep throwing under
oh my god they keep flying up sorry bro
I'm really sorry about this one oh
please do give me
oh we're back in action
I wanted to shoot there
I guess I have to go closer
I don't want to die now it's too cool
[Music]
thank you oh I forgot did I just kill
myself I on the side I forgot about the
g-man of course
amazing guys I want to be a little sappy
here
I just thank you for watching
whatever zombie on that door I still
love you
oh no no no banned gangbanging
there's the g-man of course he's the one
in the vault
it's the one that they captured
all right Gordon
let's get you out of this thing oh and
that's not Gordon let me tell you
you think am I
yeah I never had hahaha mr. Alex Gordon
Freeman yep sure Gordon Wow need to
imprison Gordon free who are you perhaps
is not as important as what I can
exchange for coming
Oh bro when was the last time you
showered on me
well fate of our worlds is inflexible
employers in a particular direction from
time to time
combine earth
I want the combine off earth that would
be a considerably large monkey too large
given the interests of my end well what
if I could do something you know free
man
high five three zero five three in there
dad what
is that me what is this what's happening
we are in the future we see the moment
where you watch your father unless what
unless what unless you were to take
matters into your own
whoa oh it's one of those oh my god
that's so creepy
oh I'm here aren't I okay so excited and
as a consequence of your action this
entity first question mark right he
lives my dad lives you are aware that
you've proven yourself to be of
extraordinary value a previous has been
unable to perform the tasks late before
here when there he is
to find a suitable replace until now bro
he's short dude no I just want to go
home send me home you misunderstand
situation wait hey wait wait wait
I mean I didn't take the job the credits
gonna roll yep
well done guys good game I was really
fun fun game this gives me hope that
there will be more VR games in the
future I think especially they will do a
full Gordon Freeman game I think that
would be really cool or maybe maybe
they'll work on a new IP with VR that
could be cool too to be honest because
that was just fun to play yeah yeah
actually play the game and I got a
decent workout it's not like a break a
sweat or anything but yeah at least I'm
not sitting still I think it's that I
think that's really cool
cool way to enjoy a game escape from the
world for a while especially in these
times I I really enjoyed this let's play
as well cuz I I just did what I wanted
usually I try to be accommodating which
I think you should be but
I don't know I guess this one might took
more the way I would just play the game
myself which was fun just having fun
with it I think it was up there with
half-life 2 I don't think it was as good
there were some parts but whatever it
was still dopest out
Shapiro
the zombie Tom thank you Tom for your
service
[Music]
for Jake
oh that's sweet anyway that's a Gordon
Freeman reference gone Gordon wait up
Gordon she's gone Gordon she's gone yes
because I was thinking it's kind of
strange how they don't have any Mele in
this game especially being a Viera game
I think that was deliberate for the
crowbar in the next game okay cool
that's it alright thanks guys